for mile after mile stretching across
ukraine a rippling green sea of wheat
this is why they call it the bread
basket of the world
when dutch farmer keith hussinger first
came here to farm 20 years ago
this is what drew him here
i mean this is
this is perfect and it's the famous
ukrainian black soil i mean it's the
best soil in the world
seventy percent of what ukraine's
farmers harvest is exported last year
feeding 400 million people around the
world but barely any of it is getting
out now with the country blockaded by
russia
making farmers like keys increasingly
desperate there's still 25 million tons
of grain
in oil seeds left in ukraine that's the
third of last year's harvest so we
already have a huge logistical problem
so it had i mean
yeah it's it's already late it's already
too late but i'm
there you know talking about like this
it makes me kind of
laughing from
nervousness you know and emotions
you're anxious i'm really anxious i mean
the only option is to get
the grain out of ukraine is through the
black seaport they have to be opened
that's the only option there's currently
enough grain stuck in ukraine's silos to
feed all the world's least developed
nations for a year the world was already
facing a food supply crisis because of
covert 19 climate change and rising fuel
prices but if ukraine can't get its
grain out of these silos and to the
international markets that crisis could
become a catastrophe
for hundreds of millions of people
on ukraine's black sea coast it's port
stand idle
we gained rare access to the port in
odessa which should be busy exporting
last year's harvest
nothing is happening here now
this is ukraine's problem and the rest
of the world over here a quarter of a
million tons of ukrainian grain in these
vast silos and across the dock here a
vessel that's got 60 000 tons of grain
in it that hasn't moved since february
because until russia's naval blockade
out at sea is lifted
none of this is going anywhere
massive silos stand full of grain but
with no means of getting it out to sea
the world food programme is warning if
the blockade isn't lifted the impact
around the world will be devastating so
there's no question it's going to mean
um areas of starvation in the world
are going to get worse
pockets of famine will get worse um and
and we're in a situation where the
world's economies are only um partially
um getting better since covert 19 and
this situation is going to tip many
countries over the edge vladimir putin
has his heel on the jugular of the
world's food supply if safe passage
can't be found through these waters the
chaos and suffering he's brought to
ukraine will also be felt far away from
here dominic waghorn sky news odessa